and i can hear
the clamor for the carriages
as they come down
the mall
and
long horse guards road and
onto horse cars we'll see them shortly
in the
trees coming down from the top there as
we hear the bands leaving buckingham
palace with the royal colonels who will
be representing
the queen later at this parade
sergeant major and bermuda
and they're leading the first carriage
the number one bruce in which the
duchess of cornwall and the duchess of
cambridge are traveling
yesterday the
duchess of cornwall was invested with
the insignia
of lady of the most noble order of the
garter by her majesty the queen
she was appointed
to the order of the garter recently and
later this year
the queen will become the person who has
held the garter longer than anybody else
in history
she was made
[Music]
the three children of the duke and
duchess of cambridge
traveling with
their mother
and with the duchess of cornwall
and in the second carriage
the ireland council of wessex with their
two children
eddie louise
in windsor
and i count seven
and in the balmoral vandal
that you can dutch the gloucester and
vice admiral sir tim lawrence
whose wife
the princess royal as colonel blues
royals
is gold sticking waiting today
and responsible
for the protection of demonic
going back